I'm here in one of my favorite places in  the Milwaukee area this is the Milwaukee  Institute of Art and Design and we're  here on the fourth floor this is the  place where I do most of my teaching and  working my office is just down the hall  you notice all this really cool student  artwork behind me this is 2D design and  it's not all that as we move on you can  see all these bottles and packages that  students design much of this is for  local  manufacturers and that's one of the key  things about Maya and if you like this  I'll shoot some more shorts along these  lines because this entire building is  chock full of student artwork from their  classes and this is one of the perks of  being here so if you like this let me  know and I'll shoot some more